[Music]
[Applause]
hey
has finally made her live-action debut
and oh boy i could not be happier with
the way she's portrayed
her looks her voice her mannerisms just
everything about her is perfect in my
opinion dave filoni has done it again
give more creative control to dave
filoni because this man knows his star
wars
this is also the first time we have seen
white's lightsabers
in live action as well and they look and
sound
amazing the suspense in this scene
really showcases how badass ahsoka tano
is the camera movement and shots and
ahsoka taino skills are perfectly
encapsulated in this scene and i'm
really excited to see where they're
going to take her character
although i don't think we'll see her in
a mandalorian again
but this really sets up her character
well for the rumored ahsoka tano tv show
to spin-off show i really hope this
rumor is true because i really want to
see where they can take this character
and
you know i want more serkitano in live
action like this was just
a brilliant episode and frankly i want
to see more
also in this episode there was some
other big reveals like grand ammo thrawn
so possibly ahsoka tano could still be
in a mandalorian as she might be
searching for thrawn because of rezro
or potentially they'll save this for a
separate show but
it seems like a big name drop for the
man lauren so possibly this will be a
plot point
i guess we'll just have to wait and see
in the meantime guys what did you think
of ahsoka tano please tell me your
thoughts in the comment section below
and with that out way
please like and subscribe and i'll catch
you guys in the next video
[Music]
you